regret feels that much worse when you're
being watched by millions of people just
ask the actors who wish they could have
done it all differently
after the runaway success of Monty
Python's Flying Circus actor and
comedian John Cleese began to work on
projects unrelated to the legendary
British comedy troupe one of his highest
profile non-python Endeavors was the
sitcom Faulty Towers which was written
by cleice and his then wife Connie Booth
the show follows basil faulty a man
running his own hotel in the British
town of Torquay as he tries to deal with
the eccentric guests incompetent workers
and the consequences of his misanthropic
and snobbish Behavior running for two
seasons in total the series is widely
considered to be one of the most
influential comedy television shows ever
Faulty Towers his popularity is such
that it is constantly rerun around the
world and Basel faulty is still
occasionally referenced in contemporary
medium including the first Deadpool
movie what is it really Kevin Ruth Scott
Mitch rickster
is it basil 40. despite all of the
critical Acclaim however police is not
entirely happy with the series there is
one scene in particular that still irks
him one that involves a moose head
falling from a wall of the hotel
speaking to the one show he explained
that the moment the stuffed head fell on
him should have been re-shot because it
didn't fall on cue and I'm very sorry we
didn't go back to do that so every time
I watch that sequence I always say oh
dear I wish we got that right but he's
even apologize that this is the edit
that ended up in the broadcast episode
Glee became a TV phenomenon in the late
2000s launching many of the actors
involved into worldwide stardom the
series follows a high school Police Club
called the new directions as they try to
find Glory at a number of regional
singing tournaments as well as its
Lively musical numbers and dance
routines Glee became famous for the way
it tackles a variety of societal
problems from homophobia to racism and
even teen pregnancy one scene was
particularly difficult for actor Naya
Rivera in an appearance on showmance or
Nomads Rivera explained how she
struggled to get through an acerbic rant
in the episode Jagged Little tapestry
the scene sees Rivera's character
Santana Lopez subjecting Kurt Hummel to
an onslaught of insults that seems
specific and personal enough to feel
targeted towards Kurt's actor Chris
Colfer she said you blurred the lines
too much and I remember like him being
upset about it and we just have to do it
over and over and over and over again
celebrity chef Gordon Ramsay has become
famous for both his skill as a chef and
his numerous appearances on television
over the years he has hosted a number of
TV shows and Ramsay has developed a
reputation for having a ferocious temper
and for being prepared to do whatever it
takes to get the job done one of his
comparatively less accessible projects
was Hotel Hell which follows a similar
format to Kitchen Nightmares on the show
Ramsay travels around the United States
as he attempts to help struggling hotels
get back on track and become successful
businesses first broadcast in 2012 it
was on the air for three seasons before
its cancellation in 2016. part of the
show involved Ramsay trying out some of
the facilities in the establishments he
visited and this is what caused one big
moment of regret for the chef speaking
to the son Ramsay later said that he
didn't love the fact that he got naked
while using his shower in one episode he
said I do regret one thing getting my
ass out in the shower Joseph Quinn
appears in the fourth season of the
hugely popular Netflix series stranger
things playing the unlikely hero Eddie
Munson he's the dungeon master of
Hawkins High School's hellfire club and
is believed to be part of a satanic cult
by many of the towns residents soon
enough Eddie is forced into hiding after
being blamed for the death of Chrissy
Cunningham season 4 of stranger things
was palpably darker than previous
Seasons offering up some pretty horrific
deaths that spooked plenty of viewers
one notable example of this came in the
first episode in which Chrissy is killed
by the Monstrous vechna while visiting
Eddie's home speaking to Screen Rant
Quinn said that the scene was not too
difficult to film but added that when he
saw the finished edit during an ADR
session he almost instantly came to
believe it should not be included in the
broadcast it showed me and I was like
there's no way you're gonna get away
with that Netflix isn't going to let you
do that but they did and yeah I think
it's horrible at one point lost was the
biggest television series in the world
the ABC sci-fi Mystery Show saw a group
of plane crash survivors stranded on a
strange Island althoughing into the past
of these various characters lost charts
their struggles to survive on the island
and uncover its hidden secrets
Evangeline Lilly portrayed Kate Austin
one of the series major characters and
felt many scenes in later Seasons
changed the way audiences perceived her
character though Kate starts out defined
by her fugitive status in Past after a
few seasons the show begins to treat her
more like a romance object bouncing back
and forth between fellow survivors Jack
Sawyer in an interview with the Lost
Boys podcast slowly said not irritated
me and I and I I did throw scripts
across rooms in the same interview the
actor spoke about her regret about a
scene in season three in which she had
to be partially nude she recalled I was
mortified and I was trembling and I was
at when it finished I was crying my eyes
out
originally airing on Lifetime you later
arrived on the streaming service Netflix
based on the Thriller novel of the same
name from author Caroline kepnes the
series follows Penn badgley's character
Joe Goldberg a bookstore manager who
stalks unsuspecting women while posing
as an ordinary boyfriend he was received
widespread critical Acclaim and quickly
found a dedicated following on Netflix
although it has attracted some criticism
for arguably romanticizing serial
killers and violent Behavior playing
such a disturbing character is certainly
a challenge for Badgley especially when
Joe does such terrible things on a
regular basis however one specific scene
caused particular issues speaking during
a Roundtable interview the actor
explained that he did not want to film
the moment when he performs a sex act
outside of gweneverbeck's house while
watching her through a window he went on
to say I found myself surprisingly
disgusted like I did not want to do it
in 2007 Blake Lively starred in the teen
drama series Gossip Girl which revolved
around the lives of privileged teens in
the upper east side of Manhattan Lively
portrayed Serena Vander Woodsen a
character who returns from a mysterious
absence and becomes embroiled in the
teen's various schemes as they try to
get ahead of each other running for six
seasons in total Lively found Fame
thanks to a rolling Gossip Girl but she
also didn't always enjoy the experience
after all her character can be a
mean-spirited and conniving individual
who was willing to do whatever it takes
to get her own way speaking to a lure in
2015 the actor revealed how she felt the
show could have put out a better message
adding that her character was not
somebody she particularly enjoyed
playing she referenced the moment in the
season 1 episode woman on the verge in
which Serena encourages a guy named Pete
to take drugs with her Lively said I
would not be proud to be the person who
gave someone the cocaine that made them
overdose
set in a fictional town in North
Carolina One Tree Hill is a 2003 teen
drama that follows the lives of a number
of high school students as they compete
to improve their social standing and
engage in a wild array of romantic
relationships Hillary Burton played
Payton Sawyer on the show a musician and
artist who is best friends with Brooke
Davis and has an on-again off-again
relationship with Lucas another of the
show's protagonists despite her initial
role as cheerleader Peyton was not
portrayed in the typical manner many
viewers would expect displaying a softer
emotional side and a great deal of
Intelligence on many occasions yet in an
interview with the drama Queen's podcast
Burton explained that one scene filmed
early in the Run left her deeply upset
during season one Peyton and Lucas
become intimate for the first time and
the script required Burton to kiss her
co-star's chest something that she was
not comfortable doing
before it was adapted in the U.S skins
was a British show that began airing in
2007 like its American counterpart the
original series focuses on a diverse
group of teenagers dealing with a wide
range of issues including sexuality
substance abuse bullying and mental
illness the British version of skins ran
for seven seasons in total and often
courted controversy over the way it
showcased sex scenes with young actors
but it is now seen as a watershed moment
for teen drama shows however actor Jack
O'Connell regretted the fact that skins
did not have an intimacy coordinator on
set to help manage the show's many sex
scenes something that is common in
movies and television shows nowadays he
told the independent that he was not
completely comfortable filming such
scenes and skins when he was still
relatively inexperienced as an actor
later in the interview the actor said
you feel very compromised and if you
don't feel that you're protected in that
environment it can be very unnecessarily
daunting other actors from the original
British version of the show have also
had issues with sex scenes in the series
Freya maver explained to the son that
she found the experience terrifying
saying I was honestly petrified just so
scared I had to go away and cry to
myself which sounds so sad meanwhile
skin star April Pearson has confirmed
that these scenes were often scary and
unpleasant to film and that she still
struggles with the ordeal more than a
decade later
before landing her role as Daenerys
Targaryen in Game of Thrones Emilia
Clarke was a virtually unknown actor in
the UK following the troubled production
of the show's pilot Clark replaced
original actor Tams and Merchant in the
role of the exiled princess the
popularity of Game of Thrones almost
immediately propelled Clark and her
co-stars to worldwide stardom playing
Daenerys was not an easy task however as
the character arguably goes through the
most development of any figure in the
entire show and while Clark is obviously
grateful for the part the role has
played in her career that doesn't mean
that it was an ideal experience the
actor has since revealed that she was
daunted by some of the more shocking
scenes in Game of Thrones the excessive
nudity that came with shooting sex
scenes was particularly problematic
largely because Clark was still
inexperienced and didn't have a
confidence to assert herself in an
appearance on the armchair expert
podcast she explained how she had felt
terrified about performing in the love
scenes and didn't exactly know what she
should do you're young you have imposter
a complex you have to do nudity yeah is
that not terrifying yeah it is
terrifying as a spin-off and prequel to
Game of Thrones HBO's fantasy series
House of Dragon contains many of the
same themes and motifs as its
predecessor after all the show is set in
the same fictional world of Westeros and
it features many of the families and
locations with Which Game of Thrones
fans will be familiar the only major
difference is that this new show takes
place some 200 years before characters
such as Jon Snow and Daenerys Targaryen
were ever born perhaps unsurprising The
House of the Dragon also boasts the same
gratuitous violence and graphic sex
scenes that earned Game of Thrones its
reputation as a TV MA rated series that
means that it's not uncommon to see the
cast involved in the kinds of steamy
love scenes that would send most other
fantasy shows running for the Hills this
is something that actor Matt Smith had a
particular problem with the one-time
star of Doctor Who and the crown plays
Prince Damon Targaryen and House of the
Dragon a member of House Targaryen who
becomes embroiled in the devastating war
of succession following the death of his
brother King viserys while he didn't
highlight one scene in particular Smith
told Rolling Stone that he felt his
character has too many sexual moments in
the series he told the publication that
he often found himself asking do we need
another sex scene
Riverdale is a CW mystery series based
on a collection of characters from
Archie Comics including Betty Cooper who
was played by Lily Reinhardt well
Reinhardt found her big break with
Riverdale she quickly grew tired of
transforming into what she called Dark
Betty the alter ego who is supposed to
give Betty the ability to express
feelings and impulses that her normal
self can't Betty couldn't make it
so she sent me instead both of the show
scenes with dark Betty ticked off
Reinhardt who felt that this version of
her character quickly became a joke she
later told Teen Vogue it just became
this weird sexual thing that people
didn't really understand meanwhile
Reinhardt told People magazine that she
also disliked portraying dark Betty
because of the wig she was required to
wear she said I hate that wig I hate it
it's just uncomfortable to be honest I
never want to wear that wig again
two and a half man is the sitcom that
ran from 2003 to 2015 and originally
featured a main cast led by Charlie
Sheen Jon Cryer and Angus T Jones over
the course of its complicated and
controversial history the show followed
the three main characters as they dealt
with Charlie Harper's hedonistic
bachelor lifestyle and the relationship
between the Father and Son Duo Alan and
Jake Harper Jones was cast in the show
when he was just nine years old despite
bringing him to mainstream attention and
effectively launching his career the
actor has since spoken out about his
displeasure with Two and a Half Men
Jones joined the Seventh-day Adventist
Church during his time on the show and
frequently mentioned how the series
conflicted with his religious beliefs
things reached ahead when he called Two
and a Half Men filth and urged viewers
not to tune in in a later interview with
the CBS affiliate Jones said it was
making light of Topics in our world that
are really problems for a lot of people
I was a paid hypocrite because I wasn't
okay with it but I was still doing it
at one point known as Degrassi the Next
Generation before it was renamed for its
later Seasons Degrassi aired on the
Canadian Network CTV from 2001 until
2015. a spin-off of earlier shows such
as Degrassi Junior High and Degrassi
High Degrassi focused on an ensemble
cast of characters who attend the
Degrassi Community School here the
students and teachers would deal with
the pressures and challenges associated
with adolescents as they go through
school but memorable moments addressing
everything from bullying to sexuality
and even mental health and drug abuse
Miriam McDonald played the lead role of
Emma Nelson on the show a headstrong and
conscientious teenager who has a passion
for championing good causes during her
Nine Season run on the show The
Character also suffers from anorexia and
other Eating Disorders this is a
decision that McDonald does not remember
fondly as a conversation she had with
co-star Cassie Steele on Instagram
revealed McDonald expressed her distaste
for the way Eating Disorders were
presented on the show and felt like
these serious health conditions were not
treated as seriously as it should have
been she was particularly aware of the
dangers of anorexia and she and her
sister who had passed away were both
diagnosed with eating disorders she went
on to tell Steele that having gone
through it so personally I just really
wish that more could have been done with
them
Degrassi next class is yet another team
drama set in the world of Degrassi
originally intended to be a new season
of The Next Generation Executives
decided to launch a fresh show instead
focusing mainly on characters that had
been introduced in the earlier show like
his predecessors next class deals with a
wide array of social issues and
challenges this time around though these
issues are more focused around the types
of struggles faced by kids from
Generation Z Lyle latal played Tristan
Milligan in next class the actor has
since spoken out about a particular
scene from the show that he hated so
much that he personally asked producers
to have it removed the scene in question
would have seen Tristan fight with Miles
Hollingsworth when the latter expressed
anger about being labeled as the gay
writer the tall argued that he didn't
think his character would ever react in
that way and that it sent out the wrong
message about labeling he said that it
should be up to individuals to decide
how they want to be labeled and that
they shouldn't be forced to take on
labels that don't represent who they are
if you need help with an eating disorder
or know someone who does help is
available visit the national Eating
Disorders association website or contact
neta's Live helpline at
1-800-931-2237 you can also receive 24 7
Crisis Support by a text send Neta to
741-741
foreign